President Trump announced he's starting
his campaign for another term Oh latest
news yeah well you know we all have your
views actually surprisingly just one
view one boo everyone else is on their
iPhone oh yeah he's starting it up did
you know that he came out he has a
slogan he started it and in like four
years
yeah he did yeah yeah he kind of did but
he has a slogan now oh really yeah
president Trump unveiled his new 2020
campaign slogan here it is
stronger safer more prosperous yeah yeah
this narrowly beat out Trump second
choice less in peachy yeah in Italy and
I've heard about this in Italy a cruise
ship with 7,000 people on board is under
quarantine because one person may have
the corona virus yeah the captain said
of the passengers I'm sorry we meant to
give you ecoli that's
[Laughter]
our intention was diarrhea yeah we don't
know how this happened and some of you
might make this news Disney is now
taking pre-orders for a life like baby
Yoda doll yeah yeah when asked to
comment Yoda said not for sex it is it's
not precise thank you thank you it's
such a creepy joke and I love it you're
all like I'm glad it's not for sex